hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu
and today we are wondering how poof's
gonna get out of this one let's get into
it episode 132
and we've done our jump cut back to the
situation i very specifically recall
saying was going to happen eventually
of course their joined minds would
reveal things frankly i find it
hilarious that at every turn prof is
having to do something more and more
traitorous to keep meruem from finding
out a single piece of information
that may now change the course of the
ant world and marowam's life almost
because they've made such a big deal out
of it like if they didn't make any deal
out of it at all mera might have just
gone huh that one
yeah kill it i don't i don't care it's
human i don't care about humans i'mma
just do it i'll just do it myself
sacrifice it
i don't think marowan would have said it
like that but i could imagine that that
pito is dead is a convenient piece of
information they don't have yet but they
soon will
they have to particularly since there's
no one else at the scene of the crime
and the crime
at the moment is gross aging and murder
or maybe it's revenge
i'm not too sure peto's headless body
now lies in a forest where it
will probably grow i don't know cat
grass or like
um evil ant kitties i'm kind of excited
by that i i kind of want to see what
happens when
i want them to find out like don't don't
end this without them finding out pito's
actually dead like that's really
important to me
i need to know i need to see those
responses anyway back on the memory game
poof's goal in life is now to run around
the world trying to beat meruem to
kamugi in a world where others are
trying to get komugi to other people
komugi is still unconscious kamugi has
no idea what's happening
you be deciding to say nothing at all
nothing at all
nothing at all is an interesting
development to me him not liking kamuki
is fair but i feel as though that wasn't
as flagged as with perth i'm probably
forgetting things though because until
his development i really wasn't actually
interested in up as a character or
really a part of the series he was the
muscle now he's the brains which is an
interesting prospect when you think
about it he went from a hymn to a himbo
and we must appreciate that we must as
meruem tries to figure out what's
missing from his mind he's getting close
he's picking up all these little things
and his memories getting jogged by names
and the fact that his brain
is consistently sending him into spasms
indicates that actually these memories
are important and will likely get
stronger i don't know that for sure
sorry that sounded really confident i'm
not that confident about it i just
expect it if you've got a memory trying
to surface it's going to get there
eventually
especially if you keep looking for
things you're missing the two
unconscious creatures on the floor are
very lucky to be alive but it'll be
interesting to hear knuckle mention
camogie
if we get that far more than anything
he's the one most likely to let slip
though chameleon's goal now has changed
in what way i'm not actually sure and i
feel as though i should know but it's
been so long since i watched his
backstory that it's hard to remember
i know penguino was his carer or
something when he was human but i'm not
sure what other goals he has
as an ant and how he'd want to achieve
them so
noting there is a gap between their aims
is the most important thing here
noticing that actually chameleon could
and might switch sides if mary's the
better option for all sorts of reasons
let's just say i'm noting but i'm not
remembering because
frankly there's a lot to remember i just
feel like
there's been a really big shift in the
show to the point where
i don't know what's important anymore so
i'm seeing all of this information i'm
being bombarded with all this
information but none of it seems
important or all of it seems important
that's kind of the problem at this stage
is
you've yeah let's continue miro made his
point this episode
about how they're all connected and he
made it intensely clear using the
powerful
aurora meruemalus at this time of year
in this part of the palace localized
entirely within this world
like the principal skinner of your perf
knew how far he could take that lie
meroem had already seen him do isometric
exercises and beaten him at them
because mirrorhem's really freaking fast
and ultimately i do expect the house to
be on fire the meal perf is trying to
serve up is
really unrealistic and it doesn't matter
what he does at the end of the day
he's betraying and lying to marowan
which is something he
was expressly asked not to do
meanwhile a woman with a burden woman
woman is palmer woman i mean she's very
much an
ant woman now what what exactly did they
do and why
is it that they are treating her like
she's a woman not an aunt i just don't
understand i mean
it makes sense i just don't understand
it you know and at this point in time
meruem is the most powerful being in the
world except for a rapidly burning out
gone and we only get to see a little bit
of that but did gon shrink back to kid
size is that what i'm seeing it's
honestly a little bit strange if that's
what i saw but in my defense he has
never-ending hair so maybe i can be
forgiven for being a little unobservant
what in blazes are they thinking going
back down into that abandoned warehouse
wait sorry we're jumping we're jumping
to uh octo buddy and palm now like we're
just jumping
we're jumping around a lot today sorry
you don't go back into an abandoned
warehouse it's a stupid idea it's
absolutely ridiculous actually no really
though it's one of those hey
yeah everything's fine we'll just stay
here in this really centralized location
where everything has happened
until they leave oh they're not leaving
i guess we'll
be here in this fake town forever then
let's just hope the kid stays asleep
because that would be
really unfortunate if she were to just
wake up and start wandering around
all in all the episode was good for
returning our heart rates to normal
after the never-ending hairy man-fest
gone
punched pito's head to dead head to dead
head hmm
and it did move the story forward in a
way that was pleasing i feel it took a
little too long really for meruem to
actually call out the fact that he knew
poof was doing some shady business
behind his back and there's a lot of me
thinking it could have comfortably
happened three or four episodes ago to
the same effect sometimes the way story
is developed or drawn out seems
unnecessary
but hopefully i'll eat my words because
something amazing could be around the
next corner there's an odd feeling that
i've hit the climax of the series though
i mean
episode 130 the last one 131 you know
was huge and now it feels like a steady
denouement to the end so i'm not sure i
love being surprised by the last three
episodes and i
i want to keep up those surprises anyway
on to episode 133
episode 133 and here we hit the most
beautiful social crisis
it sort of matches the importance of the
fight between
gon and peter without any of the intense
flavoring but it was still a very
satisfying meal
speaking of satisfying meals all the
foolishness perf has been laying out
before us has hit the best fever pitch
it can at this point what what we don't
know yet is how much information meroem
extracted from him
the idea that he gave so much of himself
to the king that is now weakened is a
fantastic little nugget to place at the
beginning of an episode that results in
the end of
yoopi i'm sad we didn't get to see his
ending but to be honest because i
appreciated his character development so
much the idea that he has given
so much of himself to meruem that
there's nothing left to him to use to
defend with is brilliant and in
retrospect it shows us that his
both of their really narrative climaxes
were when they were
narratively climaxing after the bomb the
idea that they gave of themselves so
much but couldn't give of themselves is
wonderful and i
i'm still i don't know i still feel as
though i was cheated of something
despite knowing what and how welfin's
abilities work i want to know what he
thought at death i want to know what he
dreamed or hoped would become of the
situation
i want to know his observations but the
thing is at the end of it all yoopi was
like gone he was all intent
and no subtext and so what would there
have been to gain from seeing it anyway
i don't know i really like welfin he
gets he gets a little bit of redemption
but
i'm still conflicted by all of that you
know what i did love was all the little
ways perf could have
learned that pito was dead all of the
environment shifts like he really just
had to look and a big point of this
episode was environment shifting
where before it was about ants being one
contingent we then shifted to this
hierarchy of them then we shifted to the
traitorous ones and now we've shifted to
an environment in which ants who die
are those worth squishing the ones who
need to be killed because they don't
have that messy humanity palm describes
they're the ones that become the new
enemy the thing is i still believe that
meruem is what's left of gyro
it's just about whether he remembers
that but maybe it doesn't matter hiding
komugi away so they can barter for their
friends lives or push meruem to
i don't know explode is that the
intention they're gonna try to rescue
knuckle and chameleon and then
leave as quickly as possible while
meruem contemplates his double-edged
sword
sounds really dirty but it's not it's
just a metaphor
i'm not sure what it is that palm sees
when she looks at them all but i find it
interesting that she thinks she can see
the future and i don't know how much of
that
she can see or not i've never had an
indication that she can see the future
so i'm not too
sure what to do with that information
how would the original people who hired
everyone know that merome's still alive
they'd have seen the bomb presumably but
has anyone actually managed to get word
out to send more of those
violent death roses who is it palm and
octobuddy feel bad for as they gently
place a young woman in a box and slide
her away for later
how are they hiding her from his end
have they wrapped her in palm's hair
like
it seemed like a floofy pillow that she
was wrapped in so i i'm not too sure
what's going on there
the little danger bullet that meroem
remembers he is never bested in combat
is now wrapped in a pillow in a box
underground
memory is a fantastic situation because
meruem
mentioning memory comes with its own
brand of new ideas such as the one that
if you
withhold a memory from someone you're
also withholding the learning that came
from that memory right if he doesn't
remember how he learned something it's
increasingly likely he'll make the same
mistake twice
and as soon as he remembers what the
game is that he's trying to play he
falls into thinking ahead of his
opponent who in the past was kamugi but
now
now it's poof and the way puff was
winning was by cheating and even by
cheating he wasn't able to stay ahead of
his opponent and king can't possibly
take kindly to that
and when someone turns up with the
information he does have and the
information he does
need does he then see his royal guard
all but one dead without his knowledge
as
weaker than kamugi because kamuki
realistically has managed to escape
entirely unharmed to now
while every member of the guard has been
removed one out of revenge
one out of loyalty to a past time and
now now the
last might die as a result of his own
foolishness so like three revenge deaths
and
three loyalty deaths i guess perth
managed to survive this far but now he's
bleeding
as is meroem and the music of mirom
remembering was brilliant in retrospect
because it was the combining of mary's
experience with perf's passion we
haven't seen post violin for some time
but the memory of it and
why is marowan's nose bleeding does the
rose have a special little extra built
into it has marowan managed to stall his
death or is it something else
he's been in so much pain this whole
time and i've been interpreting the
spasms he's had as a response to kamugi
and
i feel like it still probably is but
what if it's some kind of agent
she's the cure of he's looking for her
because she could theoretically cure him
the explosion probably wasn't just a
quick acting kaboom but a
slow reactant nuclear something or just
a really
really powerful bug spray because i mean
bug spray would do it he's an ant like
bug spray would do it
and now i want to know if it's bug spray
but to do that i have to stop here so
that's it from
me if you enjoyed this strange rambling
who knows what i said
click here here and here get something
to eat hydrate take a serious nap and
i'll see you
next time